- You were in like a horrific accident.
- Mmhmm.
- When you were a kid. At
it was a truck hit you.
- Cement truck.
- A big cement truck.
- A bigger kind of truck.
- Dang! Not even like an F-150.
- Not a little, not an
F-150, not an F-250, bigger.
- How did that shape you?
Because you've gotta be...
- Mangled me.
(audience laughing)
I was a very weird shape after that.
(laughing)
Obtuse?
- All the geometric angles.
- A lot of weird angles.
- No, I mean, not physically.
(laughing)
I meant mentally and emotionally.
- Yeah.
- That had to kind of change things.
You're funny.
- For sure.
(laughing)
Well, no absolutely. I think,
now I'm happy that it happened
- Yeah.
- Because I don't think I'd
be doing what I'm doing.
And it also, it gave me the confidence,
because I had to re-learn how to walk
and I couldn't walk, it
was a two year process
to gain the strength back in my legs
and learn how to walk again
and I lost all of the muscle
and I shattered everything
from my knees down
and so I had to fully re-learn,
and that's really hard to do, turns out.
- Turns out.
(laughing)
- You think, on paper, yeah,
one step, another step,
you got it.
You figured it out when you were one,
you can figure it out now.
- Oh my God.
- It was very hard. And so now
"I'm like I can do anything"
when I can't.
But I have that confidence.
- I think that a lot of creative people
have odd things that happen to them
either horrible or whatever
cause it kind shapes you
and it makes you this creative person.
You can, you know, make fun of yourself
like self deprecation.
- For sure.
- And even have no shame,
you're just like "I'm in it!"